[Music]
in no sense of humor news submitted by
JK come to China guy currently made an
elaborate first date PowerPoint
presentation and got blocked for it oh
yeah something a crazy person that's
talking weird
he made a first date PowerPoint
presentation looking fedora Sh like how
am I supposed to go or about like what
he wants this is the size of my penis
and cut right next to the eye
fluctuation see yeah it's like exactly
the same is that weird [ __ ] I got
nothing on this one I got no connection
to it I don't know why - power point you
put some effort he puts in more effort
than I ever did but there's more effort
and then there's too much effort you
know if you're gonna meet me and there
really be like I've wrote a whole
fanfiction about you and when you suck
my dick I'm like that's [ __ ] do that
yeah that's that's a nerd [ __ ] yes
there's fanfiction TV and Tommy and
Julia like what they do the like a comic
they write stories like and then Tommy
turned around and jr. on it so there's
dudes out there they have it for you
like that what is fanfiction they make
up stories like sexual stories about
like famous people how come there hasn't
been anything what about me and Julia
and Gio and I think you were in it too
and I was like like you guys are banging
it's like you're on ik porn if they
write and then people are like oh yeah
that was like a forum right and then
they put the link to the fanfiction and
I saw that there was someone requesting
like who can you do it about this and
this and that and then using this like
they're actually requested eyes
extremely attractive out there in the
world huh but the point is love you it's
a it's like a man's imagination right so
when you're reading this [ __ ] story
all I could think of is like a big burly
man that's writing and typing already
sick
he's like a buff dude little like just a
louise you dude like see like you're a
fanbase like do you should do a signing
or something yeah you do yeah I'm gonna
write a fan most of them like they're
Asian teenagers and they're [ __ ] rad
like they're so cool but you know game
you're sure yeah there are some weird
ones are just a little bit let's hear
about some of it oh don't eat the
messages Joel loves my messages that I
get I get messages all the time like six
or like a warning that recently was I
get a lot of dick pics the one was I'll
pay you $200 to write a sybian on camera
naked that's it thank God a rodeo a
rodeo or what is it the mechanical bull
a sex machine it's and then you'll do it
no but I could do it but no video
yeah no video I want to tell my feet
[ __ ] like that do they say some
perverted [ __ ] like you just be a cam
girl yeah absolutely like it's cool what
she does after though is she she
basically screenshots these things and
sends it to this guy's family because
he's doing it from his Facebook account
from their personal here I find everyone
with the same last name and their
friends list and then I find your wife
and then I send it to them you know
blast these two put them on your ID and
snuper's it just why would you would you
take money from a guy that says that all
you have to do is step on his balls with
heels and then he would give you 8 grand
for it yep I'd be scared because just do
that I'd be scared because what if he
murders and you can have three and
you've got three friends with you anyway
I don't really agree with him doing
[Laughter]
sorry some stories later but just not
that's nice it's ugly you and I will be
together for this long and will be very
happy according to this graph mm-hmm
yeah so this guy's name is Ben he's from
London he said like farter your handsome
guy power point I would hire him to be
my dick in a heartbeat like he looks
like he plays soccer you look like
Justin Timberlake if you there Ramsey
from Arsenal FC that's a big that's the
thing the fine line between being creepy
and not creepy is just be attractive
that's all that's all that's true that's
what it is because it's a [ __ ]
handsome guy did the same [ __ ] creepy
guys did it'd be a different story it's
romantic
[ __ ] [ __ ] there are the two rules
of not be creepy as one be attractive to
don't be unattractive yeah cuz if this
guy came up to your house right listen
like I'm a ball he has a British accent
- oh god like I absolutely love you
inside this box there's lingerie there's
chocolate and this is gonna be a
forecast of what we're gonna do tonight
and you're easy now my drops or they'd
be halfway to China do not flip it it's
the guy from that Japanese guy from
Heroes the one with the glasses Basu Oh
Matsoukas Masi oka ya Masi oka he comes
up here's my iowa new - where's a pen t
no but he has he's doing it you should
do some voiceover no right now oh yeah
but let's go back to Justin Timberlake
right okay look man tell me what this
beautiful last man that I hope is single
did so bent well you're gonna be sad cuz
my paintings back up so here we go
China from China I can meet give that
[ __ ] back so he tweeted this out he said
a guy asked me on a date today and said
any suggestions where it should go
because I'm a full time weirdo I sent
him a PowerPoint of ideas
that's cute it's gonna look like so they
suggestions of where to go on a date by
Ben and then his whole name and in
summary I'm not gonna read the whole
thing but just he just provides options
of near where they live
and so here's option two and option
three and then there's a conclusion as
well he did an entire presentation and
then that's when this tweet just went
viral and then people were asking or
saying this is incredible I hope you
proposed immediately no he blocked me
what a waste of MS Office Microsoft you
know was a producer of coordinator there
have been like best [ __ ] tight yeah
because that's like the same wavelength
yeah so then he ends up saying I think I
dodged a bullet because obviously this
is tongue-in-cheek and I don't want
someone who has zero humor yeah and then
Microsoft tweeted at him thinking his
loss and then his handle we know your
work will go on
that's quite sure about the iceberg but
okay sure I guess it's Titanic my heart
your heart rush don't know
that's so cool and this story just went
crazy viral cuz everyone was like that's
amazing you did an entire presentation I
wonder what it's like to look that
[ __ ] good dude like as a guy he's
ahead you know because if you see her
tell it's like that like what the [ __ ]
is that like like to walk into a room
and it was like oh my god if I want to
see him first thing you came on talk to
me I would die but the moment I hear
that accent I'm like what's that like
that's like girls with a banging body in
a beautiful face yeah right like a hot
hot girl it's the same thing like what's
that like though what's that experience
tell you we would be talentless we knew
we accepted at a very young age who we
really were that's why I was like to get
to climb up the social ladder
we got a have skills yeah excuse me yeah
nationality you gotta make them laugh so
hard that their eyes are always open cuz
like that's what it is is like what I
make you laugh so hard you forget about
this experience in America but if you're
that good looking also you can be a hoe
and make money off of yo [ __ ] let's see
how I'm saying dude it's like well how
do you get a girl look how do you get a
girl's [ __ ] well this is what happens I
started being a friend first right and
then three years later I marry her it
might happen BAM Davis oh Westside
[Music]
that's how I do that [ __ ] do I do it
extra slow I stop paid for the [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah so that's cute would like the lead
or elaborate thing that they've done to
get on a date with you what do you mean
what gender you just kept going I'll
just do it yeah I swear to god dude I'm
onna get to I might have gotten two hits
mmm but have you gone out of your way to
impress a girl like to on a date out of
your way to do anything crazy no that's
just not my fear yeah cuz I'm not like
but but I think girls are so nice
because no matter what if you have some
type of amazing talent amazing ability
[ __ ] ambition or success or you're
like alpha in what you do they'll give
you a chance you with their talent Jose
of those where the dudes are [ __ ]
living in the house I do not play guitar
hello my name is a perilous soul I swear
there's a groupie in everything I was
watching this other documented this
guy's a worm hunter he [ __ ] he puts
like a steak on the floor and then he
like rubs metal on it and he makes the
ground vibrate and these [ __ ] worms
come out right yes hitman is white they
met like an end they started [ __ ]
digging for worms and in the 70s and
[ __ ] and it's like there's a there's a
woman for every man I'm glad that that
person is out there for him yeah I'm
just I'm pretty sure like so guys just
gotta be good at what they do and Bish's
got your [ __ ] together
girls are very funny if you're overly
kind of excel if you're like the ethnic
dude right didn't you say I just come on
come on come on it's too much work to be
good looking dude yeah I mean you gotta
just [ __ ] care about the way you look
you're gonna constantly call me okay
this is just whatever whatever it does
it just did what something like unibrow
then you get rid of those but you're
fine yeah you good I tried it right here
let's support the marriage though yeah
this is the fight that I'll like you're
a beautiful woman
if Hitler can get a wife then there
really is a woman for someone well he
was very charismatic though if Charles
Manson can have groupies six holes that
dislike there's gonna be a time where AI
takes over in the sex robots or like the
AI so like the nerdy dude that's never
gone out can just go online I want that
one 20 G's boom
and then that's it happening now yeah
how does that make the females the real
doll you how does it make you feel I'm
married but like what's the weirdest way
that you've like the weirdest most
elaborate kinda weird with it anyone's
ever tried to get to you like did they
sell you a bunch of lattes and until you
know what about you my favorite one is
your sleeping manners didn't forget my
favorite one was this is actually I
don't even know how to top this one I
was working at the x-games and what is
it the staple center and we're working
the booths outside I was working for
Pelican cases and across from us it was
like a navy or army recruitment like
dude how many pull-ups we give you t a
free t-shirt and what they had a they
had like a bomb defusing robot [ __ ] or
whatever they're like a multi-million
dollar government bomb defusing robot
and it rolled over to me and in the
little clamp was a piece of paper and
like it slowly opened its [ __ ] clamp
like a month later it opened up so I
like took it out and says do you like me
yes or no and then on the robot there's
a camera and then the guys are standing
over there like looking at the screen
and then I realized I'll spending over
and then my boobs really cute that's the
best way like I got hit on by
multi-million dollar robot how do you
top that using government property to
pick up ladies that's not bad great
lucky you [ __ ] hey guys would you think
of that video I know you loved it so
make sure to hit that like button to
watch more videos and check it out up
here
[Music]